Oh Ren you're gonna [ __ ] die dude neo
is sitting in his cubicle serving one he
gets a phone call the intimate story
beat to a voice on the other end
tell them Neos are in the building
looking for you story b3 so those are
beeps the little building blocks that
make logical progression see what's in
the back
so today I'd shoot fight scene and a
dialogue tune so for the action scene
today we're not doing like stylish
choreographed action per se it's more
much more character based and meat based
there's no like that that there's none
of that going on it's very much is like
bang grab slam very concise yeah so
we're nuking these cause we're basically
yeah we're [ __ ] nuking these coins so
one of my side hobbies when I'm not
making videos for a living is collecting
and cleaning ancient coins they're
usually Roman or Greek coins that are
dug out of the ground by metal detectors
each coin is a mystery it was made by an
ancient person in an ancient
civilization and part of the fun is
finding out what these coins are
researching them and really learning a
lot about the history of when these were
made and where they came from I showed
you in a previous video which is down in
description how I clean these coins by
hand it's very painstaking process
however a lot of these coins I get are
so rusted and covered in muck that
cleaning them by hand is near impossible
if you want to preserve detail however I
think I found a technique that'll let me
expose the details of these coins I'm
going to use electrical current to
basically nucleus kind with a process
called electrolysis here's how it works
first you're going to take a simple DC
power adapter you're going to split into
wires this is going to be easily the
sketchiest part because we're going to
snip this and have to exposed ends while
it's also plugged into the wall right
there perfect yeah
the issue here is I don't actually know
which side is the positive and which
side is the negative so if you're
positive and you have your negative the
current so the wire with the dashed
lines is positive damn it oh no we're
going to attach clips to either one then
we're going to take a piece of steel I'm
going to use a spoon we're going to put
that in the water
picking out they're going to clamp the
positive side to the spoon and then the
negative side with the clip we will put
the coin this isn't a short-circuit
because there is no solution in between
each of the nodes then we'll fill the
glass with water and we'll add salt or
baking soda what's going to happen is
there's going to be all this current and
it's literally going to shock anything
that's not metallic all that rust all
that calcification all the dirt it's
going to get loosened it look like
gypsies are roaming horses or well
that's not it Fred found in the river
I've never done this before how
important is it there's two times the
coins I want to try really crusty Roman
bronze coins chosen just a couple to
test on remember other ones are these
French coins I found these in France or
when I was a kid it's going to literally
just wrap the see the wire around the
nail right you put that in your mouth so
we have our split wire adapter we also
have our solution ready to go we have
our sacrificial spoon and we have an
old-ass trusty coin I'm going to turn it
on and three two one oh there goes it's
bubbling it's blowing this level and
look at that all the bubbles are on the
alligator clip that's interesting so n
oh yeah what we're going to see here is
a large cloud of hopefully big agree
that is coming off start to form around
this point all the coin is going to
phone to that's anything not metal right
now is being separated from actual metal
core of the coin
okay it's like a fizzy drink I want to
drink it triple dog dare you
welcome to base camp on time base camp
is for all the crew parts you can't just
park in the street in from the house
Louis you have no space all right let's
get set west generators and truck I'll
make sure your phones on silent
[Music]
for tomorrow
this really is doing such a good job
yeah I get one more shot of a needle
being injected into someone's arm hi
guys here we go
and we're off the Zags and how about
this before we do it let's go frame up
the injection key just prep it so we
don't have a big bubble in there
cool cool thank you action great yeah
okay that's the end of that thing wrap
on Zack's is a wrap on okay it's been a
crazy couple weeks here we're starting
off on our third week of production as
of today this production has been a
really unique experience for us because
every single day we're shooting about
six or seven pages of just scenes and
dialogue and stuff like that every day
we're coming out effectively with the
amount of content put into like few
YouTube videos they've a crew of almost
50 people working with us on set every
day so it's because of them that we can
make all this possible every time we
choose game clear on set we always start
buying just kind of explain a really
rough walk through everything that's
going to happen we'll say well the
actors going to come through this door
here they're going to sell a couch there
so just so people have a general idea in
their mind what's going to happen the
next step that we do is usually just
bring in some standings or people just
so that people can just look at
something there and start framing at
cameras I knew that the real actors
haven't even shown up yet basically we
have to be quiet
now 20 minutes later it's already having
a huge effect let's turn it off and see
it wow yeah you see that that bran
coming through
yeah but well looks nice I think it's no
need to go back in it does there's a lot
of closet in the patinas [ __ ] which
means the value of the coin is [ __ ] to
a lot of people will be ruined this coin
in fact to me we ruined the coin but the
fact that I can now see exactly what the
coin is and even attribute it that's
cool
Oh put it back in for 10 more minutes
oh my god drink your milkshake no well
you're gonna [ __ ] die dude why does he
do things that actually walk there one
more time here all right I get it
powerfully into one don't jump on the
back office who's touching punch before
that yeah yes yes it's good so hits wall
pictures fall Nora jumps on his back he
walks me away of Ryan in that plan
ghosts have a double come in all right
okay Park okay that where I'm going this
way
choking we'll get a beat here I'll
probably be affected pastry little red
purple and endorphin second yourself up
so it's not like I'm entering him taking
it in yeah it's basically like it's like
a hit stumble back grab some like that
Bhumika wall shoot mostly and health or
figure school doing a second notice my
first
I'm counting fans coke I diet coke on
set now I switched a teeth penis bones
and then you can drink as much tea as
you are no one puts you make it five
yeah four feet okay
I'm soaking here for a while I'm going
to see if I cannot clean it up and see
if this worked I'm just going to hit
this with some steel wool to get all of
the gunk off this coin I think is done
if you can see that very clean I can see
a lot of detail pretty cool you can see
all that we chose bronze and and
majestic object on the back here it's
got like I can show your stone if they
camp gate camp gate so there's like date
there's a door to it here all the bricks
an ASIS of the midmark so I can figure
out which to be that was made in how old
is just going from pro 380 didn't really
good shape for how old it is not like a
penny Oh
the Romans just like us okay we are
using the 17 inch small HD monitors with
these monitors were able to input blood
and would you call it the ill tobacco it
was of that we're talking a lot I had to
come over here it really helps all that
have a clear idea on what like the final
image might look like so we have four
buttons here and we literally can scroll
and we have all oh is that all 250 no
other better pack out there check out
his site let's put a link in this
description because this is super cool
okay so now that I've cleaned this room
and Wayne and I know that this works for
12 years I've been wondering what the
hell this coin is yet doesnot
electricity back and see see if we can't
figure that out tonight I think red will
get a kick out of this puzzle so
remember that spoon that I was using is
my ground where's then where's the spoon
though so oh my god I need electrolysis
like murdered it it just dissolve
the whole spoon that's what's left of
the handle these are things that a jail
jailed person can get pretty sure read
you wanna write that stuff well so after
cleaning this coin it appears that it is
a 20 francs coin from 1951 so not quite
as old as the Roman coins but still
pretty cool to know it is at least it's
important to note that electrolysis will
ruin your coins it cleans them too much
it stripped down past the patina which
is an oxidation of metal the patina is
what keeps the coin valuable personally
I find that there's a lot more
historical value for these dug coins in
this clean state there's a lot more
educational value for me with these
coins being cleaned I kind of look at it
as at least I'm letting these coins
shine again and getting them out to the
world so poetic yeah nerdiest [ __ ]
thing ever so what's it arcing to why is
it not why is it not coming back to
ground so that's the primary that's the
the coil no you do not have air cooling
on that it's water cool you know what's
unreal